Speaker 1: Let's see who else
is on today. Why don't we speak
next to let's speak to Logan from
Eureka. Logan, you're on the air.
Hey, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: How are you doing? I'm doing
well. Cool. I just wanted to get your general take
on the upcoming California gubernatorial recall.
A lot of the sentiment I get I am a
bartender personally, so I get a lot of
quips from my local community. And it seems like
in general, people don't know what they're talking
about. As far as why this is happening
and why do you think people hate Gavin
Newsom so much is mostly what my question is.
Speaker 1: You know, to me, this recall effort
makes no sense whatsoever. California is growing
almost as quickly over the last six, seven years
as the developing country of China.
Economically, California is doing really well.
It whether whether you believe it's because
of Gavin Newsom or not, that's something
that can be debated. But it seems to me that I
would be looking at Californians saying, wow,
on a lot of fronts, things are looking good.
They've got a surplus. They've got a lot of
interesting initiatives. Now, those on the right
like to say you've got homelessness in cities.
It's really expensive in California, et cetera.
You know, it's expensive because there's demand.
The very people who talk about markets
seem not to understand it's expensive
in California because a lot of people want to
go to California. That's why property values
are as high as they are. Is that bad for tons of
people? Of course it is. And we should deal with
that. We should deal with a housing program.
We should deal with all these things. But
I am seeing nothing going on in California that
says to me the governor is uniquely failing and
needs to be removed before his term would
even be up. So you'd have to ask someone who
wants to do it because it makes no sense to me.
Speaker 2: Yes, that's pretty much where I'm at.
But yeah. Thanks for responding.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Yeah,
we'll continue to follow that and see what
happens. Let's go next to. Oh, how about
Veronica? Veronica, what's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Vello. Veronica. Oh, no, Sam Ceder.
Speaker 1: All right, no,
Veronica, today, that's too bad.